مرحبًا، أنا الدكتور سانجاي غوبتا مضيف بودكاست
Chasing Life على قناة CNN، الأشخاص الذين يتمتعون
بعلاقات جيدة وأصدقاء مقربين
أكثر سعادة ويعيشون حياة أطول من
الأشخاص الذين ليس لديهم تلك
الروابط الاجتماعية، يبدو أنني لم أصدق هذا
في البداية ولكنه حقيقي حقًا  وهي
تأتي من دراسة هارفارد حول
تطور البالغين والتي تعد بالمناسبة
أطول دراسة علمية أجريت على الإطلاق منذ
85 عامًا في مقاطعة
هارفارد، لذا وفقًا للطبيب النفسي بجامعة هارفارد
وأحد مديري الدراسات روبرت
والدينجر، يمكن أن تكون الوحدة سامة بالفعل،
لكنه قال أيضًا لا داعي للقلق لأن
لا يتعلق الأمر بوجود العشرات من الأصدقاء
أو حتى أن تكون في
علاقة ملتزمة، في
الواقع قد يكون الزواج المجهد الشديد الصراع ضارًا
بصحتك، ما تحتاجه هو
الأشخاص الذين يمكنك التحدث إليهم في منتصف
الليل إذا كنت في أزمة  أنت بحاجة إلى
علاقات دافئة، تحتاج إلى دائرة من
الأشخاص يمكنك الاعتماد عليهم، لذا نعم مارس الرياضة، وراقب
ما تأكله، وقم أيضًا
بتنمية علاقاتك الاجتماعية
لأنها أيضًا مفتاح
لحياة طويلة وسعيدة، ويمكنك سماع المزيد حول
كيفية تحسين حياتك.  الصحة ومطاردة
الحياة أينما تحصل على ملفاتك الصوتية
[موسيقى]